los diferentes partidos políticos del
país así como el primer ministro boris
johnson han rendido sentidos homenajes y
tributos a la memoria de decir deivid
amish quien fue asesinado hoy a los 69
años mientras se reunía con algunos de
sus electores en la ciudad de lyon si en
el sureste de inglaterra sea recordado
como uno de los diputados con más tiempo
en el parlamento casi 40 años y según el
primer ministro británico uno de los
diputados que más leyes había aprobado
en este país la policía capturó en la
escena del asesinato a un hombre de 25
años que según los medios locales es
ciudadano británico pero de origen
somalí y los servicios antiterroristas
del país están asumiendo esta
investigación el país por supuesto se
mantiene en un estado de shock de horror
que permitieron además revivir el horror
que se vivió por el asesinato de la
también diputada joe cops en junio de
2016 una semana antes de que se
realizara
referendo del break sit en medio de uno
de los momentos de más polarización
política que se ha vivido en este país
también se abrió el debate sobre la
seguridad de los diputados en este país
salvo el primer ministro y algunos
ministros del gabinete los políticos no
tienen guardia personal ni siquiera
carros privados por ello se ha abierto
nuevamente este debate y si esto tendría
algún efecto en el real ejercicio de la
democracia de los electores pudiéndose
reunir con quienes han sido elegidos la
ministra del interior crítica tel ha
pedido a la policía que de manera
urgente investigue y esclarezca cuál es
la seguridad que tienen en esto en este
momento los diputados del parlamento
británico